madame monsieur bonsoir les polices du
monde entier sont réunis à buenos aires
pour tenter de mettre sur pied un plan
de lutte efficace contre les réseaux
pédophiles qui prolifèrent notamment
grâce au système internet qui permet
sans intermédiaire et sans frontières de
se livrer à des actes les plus odieux
qui soit jacques cardoze véronique
synthèse des policiers du monde entier
réunis autour d'un sujet hier encore
table on se réunissant pour la première
fois autour de la pédophilie
les 177 est un membre d'interpol
prennent conscience de la nécessité à
combattre ensemble cette forme de
criminalité il nous faut une façon de
faire une façon de faire qui est géré
les échos une majorité pays
ce serait bien de travailler et où pip
est pas tout chacun dans son petit coin
droit puis un effort national c'est sûr
première mesure cintract la création
d'un fichier spécialisé sur les crimes
contre l'enfance une initiative réalisée
à partir d'une base de données générales
dg à la disposition d'interpol cet été
interpol séparera de cette presse go de
données criminelles générale tous les
délinquants sexuels que ce soit sur les
victimes mineures ou majeures pour
alimenter leurs fichiers sur la
pédophilie
les policiers d'interpol vont devoir
s'attaquer à ceux ci internet et son
milliard d'information constamment
renouvelée en allemagne un journaliste a
voulu démontrer à quel point il était
facile d'accéder à ces images à
caractère pédophile
lui-même dit travailler en collaboration
avec la police de son pays
on a dépassé la nuit les abus sexuels
classique que l'on voyait auparavant
d'éclat ne diffuse maintenant des images
de torture d'actes sexuels entre des
enfants et des animaux sec ou encore
d'actes sexuels avec des enfants
handicapés ou même des enfants
m'entourent
pour faire la chasse aux pédophiles sur
internet les policiers devront
impérativement contrôler ses
utilisateurs complexes
vous êtes ici dans l'une des salles de
machines où transitent des millions
d'imagés une salle géré par un
fournisseur qui n'est que le maillon
d'une chaîne jour possible de remonter à
l'auteur véritable d'un message mais ça
demande un long travail d'enquêté qu'il
faut remonter filière par filière ont
monté par étape par étape des étapes qui
conduisent toujours les enquêteurs à
l'étranger où la législation peut être
différente
autrement dit interpol se donne à partir
d'aujourd'hui et pour la première fois
les moyens de combattre la pédophilie